le sujet de la concentration économique
est un sujet extraordinairement
difficile parce qu'elle est à la croisée
des chemins entre la défense de nos
intérêts économiques et la défense de
consommateurs la défense des intérêts
économiques c'est très souvent de
favoriser des concentrations pour peser
de tout notre poids face à des géants
qui peuvent être des géants américains
ou des géants chinois l'a vu par exemple
sur la question du transport ferroviaire
et de la fabrication de matériel
ferroviaire on nous sommes confrontés à
l'émergence d'un géant chinois on le
voit dans le domaine aéronautique où on
a besoin d'une capacité critique comme
avec airbus pour faire face à boeing ou
demain à comac mais le droit de la
concurrence est là pour protéger aussi
le citoyen et faire en sorte qu'il paye
le prix le moins cher possible c'est un
enjeu évidemment décisif lorsque les
questions de pouvoir d'achat se pose
quand on regarde aujourd'hui la
situation numérique européenne certains
trouvent qu'il ya trop d'acteurs mais le
fait qu'il y ait beaucoup d'acteurs fait
que le prix moyen de l'abonnement est
très largement inférieur à ce qui existe
aux états unis donc les etats-unis ont
une puissance de feu industrielles
numériques largement supérieure à celle
de l'europe mais le consommateur en paye
le prix fort en europe à linverse vous
avez une concentration qui est plus
réduite mais un prix du cou qui est
beaucoup plus bas en termes
d'abonnements internet que ce qui peut
exister aux états unis c'est cet
équilibre là qui est compliqué à trouver
entre industrie et consommateurs
dans le cas des médias c'est encore plus
complexe parce que le consommateur est
aussi un citoyen et que l'industriel et
producteurs de contenus qui sont des
contenus sensibles donc il faut protéger
non seulement l'intérêt économique du
citoyen mais aussi son intérêt politique
c'est-à-dire son indépendance d'esprit
son indépendance de jugement
son indépendance d'information et
permettez moi de dire que dans les
circonstances actuelles on voit bien
qu'il vaut mieux avoir une diversité des
médias une diversité d'opinions d'un
monopole des médias est un monopole
d'opinion
donc ce sujet la concentration des
médias est de toute évidence un enjeu
culturel politique
économique majeur et les équilibres à
trouver sont particulièrement complexes
pour nos démocraties
s'agissant de l'économie l'état a une
responsabilité majeure que je n'ai cessé
de rappeler tout au long de la crise du
coc vide que je rappelle aussi
aujourd'hui face à une crise énergétique
qui n'est comparable qu'à la crise
pétrolière de 1973 c'est la
responsabilité de l'ordre public
économique l'état le garant de l'ordre
public économique concrètement ça veut
dire qu'on ne fait pas n'importe quoi
dans le champ économique il y a une
liberté du consommateur il ya une
liberté du producteur mais il ya aussi
un arbitre et cet arbitre c'est l'état
c'est au coeur de notre modèle
économique français c'est au coeur notre
modèle économique européen pour ça il
faut qu'ils disposent d'un droit et
d'une législation c'est le droit de la
concurrence qui a comme objectif comme
je le disais de maintenir un ordre
économique en évitant des concentrations
excessives des cartellisation des
monopoles des abus de position dominante
des ententes qui se ferait évidemment au
détriment du consommateur et dans le cas
des médias au détriment de la liberté de
conscience du citoyen
[Musique]